- [Interviewer] Yeah,
what have you learned
about men from doing this?
- They're dogs.
A lot of men cheat on their wives.
(laughs) A lot, it's crazy.
- [Interviewer] All right, Rosie.
- [Rosie] Hi.
- [Interviewer] Rosie,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Sacramento, California.
- [Interviewer] Sacramento,
and tell me about your childhood,
you had both of your
parents when you were young?
- No, I had my dad and his
mom, my mom was absent.
She was out of the picture,
but I grew up with my dad.
- [Interviewer] Where was your mom?
- I don't know, out running
the streets probably.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- It was decent, it was fair
until I was 10 years old,
when my grandma passed away,
I mean it went to shit from there.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of stuff went on?
- I ended up in the foster system.
I was pregnant and
became more (indistinct)
and pregnant at the same time.
- [Interviewer] Pregnant at what age?
- 14.
- [Interviewer] 14.
So you have you have children today?
- Yes, I do.
- [Interviewer] How many kids?
- Six.
- [Interviewer] Six kids?
- Yes.
- Did you raise your kids?
- No.
My two youngest ones, I
raised them until recently
and then I had to give
them to their grandma,
'cause I've got it hard.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
how far do you go in school?
- Ninth grade.
- [Interviewer] Ninth grade?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you
started doing this kind
of work at what age?
- Three months ago? Four months ago.
- [Interviewer] Oh, just recently?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So how did this happen?
You just got money's tight?
- Yeah well, I talked to a friend of mine
and I asked him about like stripping
and then we got into the escorting stuff
and that's how it happened.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- So.
- [Interviewer] So you're new to this.
How has it been so far?
- Yes and no.
It's been up and down a
little bit up and down.
I've had good days, I've had bad days.
And it being in Reno,
I had way more bad days than good days.
- [Interviewer] Oh, doing this in Reno is-
- Yeah, sucks.
- [Interviewer] So what was
it like in Reno for you?
- Horrible.
- [Interviewer] In what ways?
- It was horrible,
I met a lot of fake people.
I met some real people.
I went through
something traumatic just two weeks ago
but all in all I'm okay.
- [Interviewer] What kind of stuff
have you encountered on the street?
I hear a lot of stories, and
nothing would surprise me.
- A lot of things that I've
encountered on the streets?
- [Interviewer] I meant like
have you had problems with tricks?
- I have what?
- [Interviewer] Have you had problems
with some of the tricks
that have picked you up?
- Yes and no.
No, not really, no.
I mean, they didn't wanna pay me
the money that we agreed upon.
(interviewer laughs)
Or they would wanna take me
in this big old goose chase
over some money, and I'm
just like, "Okay, whatever."
But nothing really too serious.
It was more so the people
that I was in a circle of
like friends, you can call it,
that did me more dirtier than
my actual tricks did, so.
- [Interviewer] And what's
been your experience
since you're new at this?
You know, what are the ups
and downs of this lifestyle?
The money is fast, right?
- Yeah, the money is fast,
but me being a new person,
and a newcomer in this industry,
it's like kind of harder for them
to think of me as somebody
that's not a catfish.
'Cause I've been told that my
profile looks fake (laughs).
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you're
working without a pimp?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Is that problematic?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No?
You're doing this on Figueroa Street?
- I haven't really done
it out here in LA yet.
I had just been in LA for like seven days.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So I just got out here, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So Sacramento, you do it
on the street or on-
- I've done it on Stockton Boulevard,
I've done it in Oakland,
but I mostly post ads.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So.
- [Interviewer] And are
drugs part of your life?
- Drugs are a history,
they're part of my history, yes, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Which drugs
have you played around with?
- Heroin, Cocaine, Meth, Ecstasy.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
Pretty much all of them.
- Shrooms (laughs),
pretty much all of them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So.
- [Interviewer] In the lack
of support in your family,
do you feel like that was
a factor in where you are?
- No, I think it was more so
the factor with my family,
it was, I pushed myself away from them.
'Cause I just couldn't bring
myself to come around my family
when I was under the influence, so.
- [Interviewer] So you were
using drugs at an early age?
- Well, I started at 18.
- [Interviewer] But you
went to the foster system
earlier, didn't you?
- Yeah, I was in the
foster system earlier.
I was only smoking weed then,
I wasn't introduced to hardcore drugs
'cause I wasn't out there
like hardcore, hardcore,
until I was 18.
- [Interviewer] So how has this
new career for you affected you?
Do you get depressed
about doing it sometimes?
- No, not really.
When I go into it or like
when I go to meet a client
or something that, I go into it
and I shut off my emotions or
the feelings that I would have
like the pleasure feelings
that you would get out
of anything like that.
I shut it off.
- [Interviewer] It's just business.
- Yeah, it's just business.
I just gotta get the money
and get out, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
what have you learned
about men from doing this?
- They're dogs.
A lot of men cheat on
their wives, (laughs) lots.
It's crazy.
- [Interviewer] And does
it build your self esteem
doing this work or does it undermine it?
- It doesn't really
undermine my self esteem.
It doesn't even boost it either.
I mean, I think it's more so
I have a lot of confidence in myself.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- So like, even if I didn't have this,
if it was in a long-term career,
or a long-term something that
I was looking for a longterm
it wouldn't bother me to get out.
I wouldn't feel less of
myself or more of myself.
I think I'm more so feel less of myself
because I should have been making
a lot of money by now (laughs).
- [Interviewer] Are you doing
this because of like COVID
and job layoffs and things like that?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So it's just,
you find yourself in a corner,
in a jam, and you needed to
do something to make money?
- Pretty much.
- [Interviewer] Did the shame
play a part in your life
now that you're doing this kind of work?
- The shame?
I mean it's more shameful.
No, not really.
- [Interviewer] No?
- I can't really say that, that's honest.
I don't feel shame in it.
It's like, I'm very
careful and I'm very safe.
So I mean, if I was out
there selling my body
for like 40 bucks a pop,
then yeah I would probably feel shameful,
but I don't do it to get high.
I don't do it to support my drug habit.
I do it to keep money in my pocket.
- [Interviewer] To survive.
What mistakes have you made
that you've learned from?
- In life or-
- [Interviewer] Or just
in this line of work?
- In this line of work?
Make sure I get the money first.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Make sure it's a for sure thing.
'Cause sometimes like I
go out for an out call
or something and they'll send me
to this bogus ass address, you know?
- [Interviewer] Are they doing it online?
- Yeah, posting ads, yeah.
'Cause I'm really, I'm not
too much of a streetwalker.
I like to post my ads and chill inside,
'cause I get a little bit of anxiety
when I have too much attention on me, so.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Oh yeah, I have.
- [Interviewer] You've
had good relationships?
- Yeah, for the most part.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
What was the best time of your life?
- The best time of my life was in 2017,
when I had my son.
I mean, I've had six
best times in my life,
but I had my son and I got
my daughter back from CPS
and I married the love of my life,
but he's not here now, he's in prison.
- [Interviewer] Sorry about that.
What are your plans,
to walk away from this?
- [Rosie] My plans is to
yeah, walk away from it
sooner than I expect.
I haven't hit the big money yet, you know,
so I think that's why
it's like not weighing down on me.
And I think that's why
it's probably easier for me
to walk away from it now
than it would have been
if I was hitting the
money, on top of money.
- [Interviewer] Is that
why you came to LA,
to make more money?
- [Rosie] No, I came to
LA to get away from Reno.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) Understood.
- [Rosie] Or two people from Reno, so.
Yeah, I had to, I was
supposed to be in Arkansas,
but it started raining or snowing,
so they closed the roads down
and I had a delay from
my bus and still delayed.
So I'm in LA.
- [Interviewer] And who's
raising your kids right now?
- [Rosie] Their grandma.
- [Interviewer] Their grandma.
- [Rosie] Yes.
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give to somebody
who's short on money and
thinking about this as a career?
- Go in it with somebody who knows
what they're talking about,
and if you're a girl,
don't do it with a pimp.
- [Interviewer] So how do you
do it with somebody who knows
what you're talking
about but isn't a pimp?
- Well, for the most
part I got all my lessons
or all my tips from a female.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- Yes.
I just I would sit back
and I would watch how
she would do her stuff,
and, or I would sit back and watch
how other girls did theirs,
and then I would take notes you know.
- [Interviewer] Are the other
girls helpful to each other
in terms of like showing
a newbie the ropes?
- No, yeah, for the most part.
Yeah, some of my friends
were kind of standoffish
because it wasn't something
that anybody would ever see me doing.
But when I started it,
they were kind of shocked,
and they were like, "Rosie, are
you sure you wanna do this?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I don't
wanna be broke," (laughs).
So for the most part yeah.
- [Interviewer] Was it difficult
the first time for you?
- The first time?
No, because I did, when I first
started out doing this stuff
in this line of business,
I did have a pimp-
- [Interviewer] You did.
- But he was the only pimp I've ever had.
And the only pimp I will ever have.
- [Interviewer] What was the
problem with that relationship?
- I got a smart ass
mouth and I don't listen,
and pimps don't play.
So,
and on top of it I had to
live up to my nickname,
which was Renegade Rosie.
- [Interviewer] Mmh,
so now you're renegade?
- Now I'm a renegade (laughs).
- [Interviewer] And what's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- The most important lesson learned
that I've learned in life
is to not trust everybody,
'cause I'm the kind of person
that trusts everybody, but-
- [Interviewer] In this line
of work it's gotta be tough
to trust anyone 'cause-
- Oh, in this line of work,
it's kinda tough to figure out
who your real friends are.
Because if you have real friends
they really wouldn't care
if you had money or not.
But the snakes and the fakes
they're only there for
the money and the drugs
and whatever they can get from you.
So as long as you keep handing them out
they're gonna keep their hands out.
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- The worst time of my
life was two weeks ago.
- [Interviewer] What happened?
- I got tied up and tortured four hours.
- [Interviewer] By who?
- Some ex-boyfriend of mine.
Well, he was supposed to be my boyfriend.
- [Interviewer] That's
why you ran away from-
- That's why I left Reno.
- [Interviewer] You believe in karma?
- Oh yeah, I believe in karma.
- [Interviewer] How has karma
played a role in your life?
- She did play a big
role, 'cause I used to be,
I used to get nervous about
like doing these clients
that I would just get the
money and not do anything
and take off, you know?
And sometimes it's kinda bad,
and I've done things in my
life that ain't too good.
But I do believe that what I dealt with
last two weeks ago was my bad karma.
- [Interviewer] It was your payback.
- I feel like that was my payback.
And from here on out, I ain't
even gonna mess with karma,
'cause that bitch is real.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have to worry about police,
getting arrested, and stuff like that?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No.
It's easier when you're
doing it online, right?
- Yeah. Pretty much.
'Cause it's like, when you ask a question,
"Are you affiliated with law enforcement?
Or "Are you a pimp?"
And they have to answer honestly.
- [Interviewer] You're asked that
just to make sure it's not a cop.
- Yes.
Because if they tell you no
and they really are a cop
then it goes against all the rules.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
Do you feel like something
in your childhood
if it was different,
may have changed the
direction of your life?
- Yeah, a lot.
- [Interviewer] Like
mom being your picture?
- Mom being there, not having
to be in CPS, a lot of things.
But I wouldn't change my past for anything
because in my future
it's gonna be something
that's gonna help save
somebody else's life.
A lot of people call me a
warrior, but I'm just human.
- [Interviewer] You're
strong and you're hopeful?
- Very much so.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Those are
great qualities to have.
- I still smile, I still
see good in the world
when there's evil out there, so.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
All right Rosie, thank you
so much for talking with me.
- [Rosie] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And I wish you
the best of luck out there.
Be careful.
- [Rosie] Thanks.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.